today the issue becomes complicated
chechnya or chechen republic has
recalled the most important geopolitical
problem for the soviet union first and
then for the russian federation we find
ourselves here in a territory located on
the northern flank of the great caucasus
mostly flat and not very rich in natural
resources bordering georgia to the south
and three other autonomous republics of
the russian federation to the west
within gushetia and north of sesia to
the east with dagestan and to the
northwest with the russian cry of
stavropol it's not easy to establish the
productive potential of chechnya which
has been almost wiped out by the
destruction of war as far as industrial
plants are concerned and seriously
weakened in the agricultural sector as
well the main resource is the transit of
the oil pipeline linking the dagestan
city of mahatkara and the city of baku
in azerbaijan on the western shore of
the caspian sea with novarosis on the
black sea today's video is not intended
to be a detailed reconstruction of the
contrasts i would say almost secular
between this rebellious republic and
moscow because my friend simone has
already talked enough about it my intent
is rather to talk about the rise of its
current leader ramzan kadyrov because
even if officially chechnya today
presents a facade of peace and
reconstruction after the two conflicts
that have opposed it to the suffocating
grip of neighboring russia the tyranny
of its ruler established with the silent
blessing of the kremlin continues to
eradicate even the mildest forms of
descent through the law enforcement and
security agencies under his control
ramzan has used brutal methods of
repression abductions enforced
disappearances torture extrajudicial
executions and collective punishment
practices not only against the suspected
armed insurgents and their suspected
collaborators but also against other
action groups deemed inconvenient such
as independent journalists salafist
muslims drug users and those called
drunk driving let's take a few steps
back at the dawn of the third millennium
after larger scale russian military
operations had brought the chechnya back
under federal rule the kremlin gradually
began to hand over responsibility for
governing the republic and conducting
counter-insurgency operations to
pro-russian chechen leaders in his 2000
speech to the federal assembly putin
portrayed the chechnya as the supreme
obstacle to be overcome to hold the
country together saying russia has
received the fundamental challenge to
its sovereignty and territorial
integrity it has come face to face with
a force striving to redraw the
geopolitical map of the world the
domination of chechnya would have been
the cornerstone of putin's project of
building a strong state because it was
the emblem of the kremlin's control over
its subordinates putin's administration
through collaboration with the kadyrov
family set up the so-called policy of
chechenization that is changing the
nature of the conflict from russians
against the chechens to good chechens
against the rebel chechens and it's
likely that the russian president in
order to reinforce his statist vision
and end the ongoing conflict needed to
find the local lord with whom the local
population could identify and who knew
the intricate traditions of the country
it was necessary to appoint as president
someone who had the past in the ranks of
the insurrectionists and therefore enjoy
the good popular support ahmad
khadirov's past seemed a guarantee in
every aspect he was a sufi muslim who
didn't identify himself with the
salafists the radicals but who
ironically after becoming a grand move t
in 1995 that is the highest religious
authority in chechnya accepted to bless
the jihad against the russian state
siding with the separatist wing led by
the then president jokar dudayev later
the salafists criticized him for being
too lenient which was unacceptable in
their project of real and pure islam as
a result a conflict developed between
sufi and salafist muslims and eventually
ahmad chose to align himself with the
russian leadership and strengthen sufi
rule in chechnya unfortunately for the
kremlin ahmad was not an efficient
puppet he was despised as a corrupt and
cold-hearted politician who argued with
the political partners and civil
administrators that moscow entrusted to
him he preferred to rely on his
relatives and his own security force
known as the zlush babies nasty or
kadyrovzi led by his son ramzan in the
meantime the second chechen war raged
and the chechenization policy didn't
seem to bear fruit as rebel cells
sprouted up all over the country
flooding the media with news of
instability related to the small
caucasian region the climax came in
october 2002 when a commando of rebels
in the service of the insurrectionist
leader shamil basayev besieged the
dubrovka theater in moscow and held more
than 800 people hostage demanding the
withdrawal of russian forces from
chechnya and the end of the conflict the
subsequent raid by the russian special
forces led to the death of about
hostages almost all of them suffocated
by gas shamil named after the famous
warrior imam shamil who led the
resistance of the mountain tribes
against the tsarist armies in the 19th
century claimed the responsibility for
numerous attacks after an incursion into
neighboring dagestan in 1999 he
repeatedly threatened to attack russian
cities even boasting that he had an army
of black widows chetan female kamikaze
his organization planted a bomb in the
moscow subway on the morning of february
6 2004 killing 41 people finally ahmad
the judge the traitor also fell victim
to bazayev's murderous rampage when on
may 9 2004 two days after receiving his
second term as president a bomb exploded
at the stadium in grozny where the
chechen leader and the number of senior
chechen and russian officials were
attending the world war ii victory day
celebration blind to the growing threat
the kremlin continued with its
chationization policy while waiting for
ramzan still too young to reach the
minimum age of 30 years to govern he
designated aloo alkanov as ahmad's
successor however he had no popular base
lacking the charisma and influence that
had distinguished his predecessor
surrounded by many questions about his
real ability to manage a region
devastated by war and to convince the
chechen rebels to lay down their arms
his election took place the weekend
before the event that triggered the
decisive change in putin's approach to
the chechen issue namely the hostage
crisis at the beslan school in north
ossetia on september 1 2004. on that day
more than 330 people lost their lives
many of them children and putin had to
open his eyes to the obvious failure of
his policy four years later in a speech
putin stated that he had underestimated
the complexity and the danger of the
processes taking place in chechnya
failing to react adequately and showing
a weakness it was necessary therefore to
create a new system of forces and means
to exercise control over the situation
in the north caucasus concepts are fully
embodied by the protagonist of our video
ramzan kadyrov he is the master of
chechnya a man who contrary to
expectations has managed to monopolize
power over the chechen security forces
in the territory still it was hard to
expect this from a man who appeared in
audiences before putin dressed in a
training suit and who given his poor
education made every public speech a
shameful disaster in spite of this
kadyrov knew how to operate within the
network of the numerous chechen tapes
the clans and balance power among them
perfectly which explains much of his
strategic success and popularity in the
eyes of his fellow citizens the chechens
are in fact a complex society based on
extended families the tape in fact and
tradition dictates that the omnipotence
of a single tape is unthinkable because
power must be distributed equally among
the various clans according to a
horizontal structure of government this
is precisely the reason that led to the
fall of president ahmad who probably
knew his time was running out when he
affirmed the supremacy of his clan
without consolidating it having to look
more to his hold comrades in arms than
to the neighboring russian giant but
khalif jr didn't repeat his father's
mistakes and enjoying the support of the
kremlin he was able to spend his
resources to concentrate on internal
affairs taking all the risks involved
and eliminating potential rivals the
centralization of power required the
first and foremost to get rid of anyone
who dared to challenge his military
authority especially influential
warlords such as members of the
yamadayev family said magomed kakiev and
mawla di baisarov the yamadayaf brothers
and kahiev commanded the vostok and
zafad battalions respectively each about
900 men strong and the only ethnic
chechens in the russian defense ministry
structure that weren't under chechen
government control zapad formed in 2003
was pro-russian and at the time of the
first chechen war in 1994-1996
opposed the separatist leader dudayev on
the contrary the vastok was formed by
former rebels who passed to the russian
side during the second military campaign
and thanks to their loyalty and
efficiency on the field for the first
time in the modern history of russia
three brothers of the same family the
yamadavs were decorated with medals for
bravery thus enjoying not only the
admiration of moscow for the courage
shown in battle but also the control of
the commercial center of gudermas a city
that lies on the railway junction
between rostov-on-don baku astrakhan and
mazdok there has never been good blood
between the yamadaya family and the
khadirov family and animosity exploded
in april 2008 when fighters of the
vostok battalion engaged in a shootout
with members of ramzan's personal guard
resulting in several deaths in
retaliation the yamadav's older brother
ruslan a former douma deputy was killed
in moscow five months later sulima
commander of the battalion and military
pride of the family managed to escape
from russia and settled in dubai but in
march 2009 adam the lincoln of ramzan's
right hand man had him assassinated
kakiev instead the head of the zapad
battalion then abolished in 2008 was the
only one to survive because he never
questioned ramzan's power finally
mahladi bazarov had been the head of
ahmad's personal security service and
after his death in 2004 he set up the
guardian's security unit on his own
directly reporting to the federal
security service but bizerov was one of
those who liked to play with fire since
he openly criticized ramzan several
times until he released in october 2006
an interview to moscow news in which he
defined him as a medieval tyrant the
reaction of the chechen leader wasn't
long in counting and in fact the
following november baisarov was killed
in moscow by a team of chechen policemen
the goryet's unit disbanded and its
fighters reintegrated in various units
of the chechen ministry of interior once
the main rival forces were defeated the
way was clear for kadyrov he was able to
monopolize the sphere of administration
in the small republic and moscow is not
only uninvolved in church and internal
affairs but receives no information
about the real state of affairs one
could almost say that what happens in
chechnya stays in chechnya and the fact
that the circumstances of natalia
stimirova's murder in 2009 are still
unknown as a concrete proof of that
estemirova a russian activist who worked
with investigative journalists anna
politkovskaya and human rights lawyer
stanislav markelot both of whom murdered
in 2006 and 2009 respectively
documenting hundreds of cases of abuses
in chechnya by government security
forces she carried out her research for
the human rights organization memorial
and was therefore branded as an
undesired person in the eyes of ramzan
who repeatedly stressed his willingness
to silence her forever so that morning
of july 15 2009 when according to the
moscow office of human rights watch
estimirova was kidnapped near her home
in grozny and then found dead in a
wooded area near the village of ghaziart
in ingoshetya there was little doubt as
to who was behind the kidnapping the
problem is that there has never been a
tough stance against ramzan from the
kremlin in fact even though vice
president dmitry medvedev expressed the
indignation and the murder and order to
take all the necessary measures to carry
out the investigation he always rejected
all hypotheses about kalirov's
involvement in the crime
on a
after all there is a dark power packed
between the federal government and small
republic that mustn't be revealed to the
outside world ramzan was charged with
creating the illusion of a peaceful and
flourishing chechnya by any means
necessary which explains his use of
violence outside moscow's control in the
2016 elections ramzan confirmed his role
as the undisputed leader with almost 98
of votes in favor and from that moment
until the present day he has continued
his war against political opponents and
insurgents but why was such a high
degree of consensus reached simple
because in the months leading up to the
vote the authorities undertook fears to
crack down on anyone who thought the
total loyalty to cadillac was
questionable among them were ordinary
people expressing dissent through social
media russian journalists like boris
nyemsov a critic of the chechen
leadership who was assassinated in
moscow on february 2015 and the very few
human rights defenders who dare to
challenge abuses of power by church and
law enforcement and security agencies a
recent report describes contemporary
chechnya as a totalitarian state within
a state characterized by kadyrov's
interference in nearly every aspect of
social life including politics religion
academic discourse and family matters
many experts describe his orders as
being in practice at the only law in the
republic thanks to the cult that has
been created around this figure the main
driving force behind this cult is
grosney tv and state radio whose news
and current affairs programs often
depict kadhirov while also blaming local
high officials for their mistakes it's
well known is intensive use of social
media to set its public agenda identify
and smear enemies think that his
instagram account which he launched in
february 2013 before being banned by
zuckerberg's company had about 1 million
followers in 2015. in more recent times
despite ramzan professing his loyalty to
vladimir putin himself his insistence on
having a free hand in chechnya has
apparently begun to test the kremlin's
patience moscow has condemned albeit in
mild terms some of his more outrageous
actions such as his public efforts to
destroy the homes of alleged rebels and
the numerous fires that followed saying
that no one including kadyrov has the
right to impose extrajudicial punishment
but these are just words and it's
difficult to believe that in the near
future the situation will change also
because moscow needs someone like
kadyrov to keep at bay a territory where
tensions are dormant ready to explode
again well we are done i hope i've kept
your attention up to the end and i'll
see you in the next video ciao